هناك عند الطرق بحسب الخبراء تساعد على
انشاء البيئه عمل قويه اولها تقديم فرصه
تعلم اشياء جديده باستمرار او سقي
المهارات الموظفين الحاليه من خلال اضافه
مجموعه متنوعه من برامج التدريب الحفاظ
على التواصل مستمر مع الفريق ومشاركه
اهداف الشركه واسباب قيامهم بمهام العمل
المختلفه وسيؤدي ذلك الى ترسيخ معنا العمل
الجماعي لديهم تقدير العمل الجادراك كل
عضو في الفريق انه يمتلك مهاره مختلفه عن
العود الاخر هو امر بالغ الاهميه لذلك
احرص على اخبارهم ان الامر بدونهم سيختلف
وان كل عضمهم في دوره وان مهمه لا تقل
اهميه عن مهمتي يعد اخر التحفيز عبر تجربه
مختلفه لقائل موظفين وتحفيزين كقديم
مكافاه ماليه او زياده في المنبه او
ترقيات او مجرد تقديم خطابات شكر
انشاء مكان عمل جذاب فالدراسات تشير الى
ان الانتاجيه تزداد بشكل الملحوظ في مكان
العمل جذاب ويمكن الالوان مثل الازرق
والاخضر والاصفر تحسين التركيز وزياده
الابداع بالاضافه الى السماح لموظفين
بتخصيص مساحه عملهم وجعلها خاصه بهم